[Music]
a ninja
with a sword a sailed a u.s army special
ops unit in california why wait what did
they know what was happening oh my god
seems unlucky but it did happen a man
wearing full ninja garb attacked members
of the us army special opera uh
operations unit in the middle of the
night in the california desert how
setting off a scramble for safety and
resulting in at least two injuries
according to police and other records is
the ninja dead does the ninja get away
safely do you want me to spoil it you
want me to look smoke bomb dude he's
smoke bombed out do you guys remember
american ninja that was a special forces
i love that
like when he would go in the corner he
was doing [ __ ] ninja stuff like that
[ __ ] man and then he'll disappear or
some [ __ ] you do this for like three
minutes yeah beverly hills ninja dude
yeah
one of the best one he still holds up i
watched it still [ __ ]
surf ninjas his benihana covered up
well everyone's left like that's the
best part dude
that you know that was original kung fu
panda
yeah you know for sure yes yeah it was
totally up to you yeah yeah the whole
white guy appropriating martial arts all
right incident occurred a little after
1am on september 18th when authorities
in ridge crest california got away would
[ __ ] you up
got word of a sword-wielding man dressed
as a ninja on the loose at the inyo
current airport in current county north
of l.a queen county sheriff deputies
found the suspect had assaulted a victim
at the scene with a sword and thrown a
rock through a hangar a window hitting
an additional victim in the head that's
a distraction
as it
did
what was this whole [ __ ] he was trying
to kill some special ops guys this is
amazing one i'm sorry not amazing did he
break into a base no uh i guess um used
a grappling hook an airport an airport
um a military airport airport there's a
hangar there no there's guys you haven't
seen like a lot of uh western films but
they use grappling hooks do you know
what ninjas do bart
i love western yeah
he doesn't watch any [ __ ] movies dude
you know those clint eastwood uh ninja
moves
the attack came without without any
warning victims are members of the uh
160th special operations aviation
regiment or soar according to the start
of the strife's newspaper which states
that the military personnel were at the
airport as part of training exercises
right and this ninja [ __ ] comes up to
this dude a staff sergeant who's smoking
a late night cigarette near an airport
hangar
all right this unknown person wearing
it's like a movie dude you got the watch
out guys
i'm not really sure what we're looking
for exactly and this ninja goes up to
him and he says literally wherefore he
goes do you know who i am the man
sergeant says he does not and then he
goes do you know where my family is mad
ass the sergeant said he did not know
the person in ninja guard began to slash
at him with a katana sword the report
states adding that the sergeant's leg
and phone were struck
leg and phone so he had a phone in his
pocket was the ninja upside down in
front of him
from the grappling hook while he asked
him this oh spiderman kiss i always love
a good spider-man that's his spider-man
i'll [ __ ] around this guy's mentally ill
yeah this moves watch too many ninja
movies this is the real deal that's what
i'm saying this happened in california
so he got to on a military base
and an airport here yes on a military
base but still that was like defended by
the military technically proving during
a training exercise they don't have
anti-ninja training they don't have
anti-training and that's a huge problem
i don't know if they'll ever be able to
have anti-ninja training that's the
whole point of ninja no you capture a
ninja then you have him training the
military they better suppress
they better suppress us from the u.s
media because if other [ __ ] countries
get a hold of this they start sending an
engine
imagine taliban who just got bumper cars
they're going to start doing ninja [ __ ]
we're going to be [ __ ] oh my god
ninjas and bumper cars and it's really
the taliban
what a [ __ ] reveal
oh my god dude tell them to take off
their faces really ninjas do you know
who i am
through the ninja masks you've already
seen the shape of the turban anyways
they have to wear it what if you
responded like no matter what they have
to wear it doesn't show his eyes it
shows his turban color that is
all these guys are rushing
that's that's the third reveal
so the sergeant runs jumps the fence
reaches the building where he joins
others from his company and he and the
captain locked doors and called
kicked and punched the 911 and windows
according to the report which has
redacted the service members names and
the rich quest uh police department um
says the report came in at 1 19 a.m of
suspect in a ninja outfit complete with
a sword at the airport citing at least
one victim uh and then after that they
uh several flashbangs
and then he was gone
they said the man refused to follow
commands when they were telling him to
stop brandishing his sword and he still
did uh they said it was ineffective
instead that man ran the death deputies
used a taser on him and he dropped the
sword and then the deputies were able to
take him into custody and he's uh he's
identified as gino rivera aged 35
mexican ninja i want to know how he ran
away he's a mexican could be filipino we
don't know we couldn't hear it i'll tell
you that
could be filipino if he had the ninja
shoes
this guy's mentally ill why didn't they
open fire on a guy [ __ ] wielding a
sword this is la because they were like
we gotta figure it out because he had a
weapon they didn't want it like dude
he's gonna cut all the bullets don't do
that i've seen
people seeing how this works
if you just go like that you get all
every bullets ricochet
and then we're all [ __ ] yeah then they
yeah he's cutting bullets in half bro
looks like this
he's gonna [ __ ] bounce it back at us
like a baseball did he ever reveal his
motive well all all
all they revealed all they revealed is
that guy goes up to somebody who says do
you know who i am and then he goes do
you know where my family is he should
have been like oh bob
that would have thrown them off this
guy's clearly delusional [ __ ]
cerritos
see
that's funny because this is just some
straight up central california in yo
county is all the way out there where i
go camping and [ __ ] there's nothing
there just a bunch of trees and [ __ ] and
one ninja one ninja where did this guy
come hey if there's more of those though
oh [ __ ] what if there's like a ninja
camp out there yeah the foot clan oh
do you know who i am hamato yoshi the
foot clan what uh what movie did this
guy get his backstory from
that's the real question where they
killed his whole family american ninja
did his whole family die or something
wasn't he like raised by japanese people
and that's why he understood ninjutsu
yeah i mean if he was raised by white
people
that's good for comedy well that was the
best thing about three ninjas is that
it was two white parents but then she
had an asian grand dad for some reason
yeah because she's supposed to be like
part asian yeah what was the one where
hulk hogan was in
suburban commando dude no no but it was
ninjas no no it was three ninjas it was
a kid movie but then they meet the third
one really that's mega mountain that's
the one
[ __ ] yeah dude that's the one where they
go to the music park
wait is that when they when they have
the little tuck talk and then they talk
together on through the cans yeah that's
the first one yeah the cup got a cup
yeah it's the first one yeah
they were both white and then grandpa
was asian
grandpa was like mr miyagi with a [ __ ]
up eye yeah one eyes
oh yeah
always like yeah he was always he always
had that same expression on his face
just always piss off that tum tum
why did he have that expression on smell
and he did that for every movie every
movie like asian every [ __ ] movie he
did a child too with eddie murphy oh
yeah he always did that i wonder if
that's his eye his eyes really like that
maybe he was like forest whitaker and he
just had like those eyes it's so funny
how they literally typecasted another
old japanese man from pap morita what's
the name yo for sure that's
like they're like
karate kid was amazing he just said no
that's all you know
let's get another old asian guy with a
weird eye yeah they shouldn't get him
dude couldn't they couldn't get pat
marita so i got that guy i kind of have
a lazy eye i don't know i'm sure he can
play lazy
his eyes both look hard-working yeah
yeah he might have been
i don't know if he passed no no he
probably didn't pass in 2001. okay so he
was still alive he was born in 1927 you
know that's great
you know he started off he's stand up
[ __ ] no not him but pat maria start off
as a stand-up comedian yeah yeah in
vegas right and he's talking about that
i'm talking about the grandpa and he
would make asian jokes like back then
[ __ ] great he was in happy days too
oh yeah
that's how he first got known yeah he
was the cook at happy days oh [ __ ] he
passed in 2005. pamarita rip
legend bro he was born in 19. you know
miyagi's in hollywood that was his place
1930s
that was his restaurant yeah
which one miyagi's in hollywood that was
his
oh sorry i was thinking about yamashiros
who won that one
i think it's something else now and it's
got the bull
it's right by the comedy
i think it's saddle ranch now oh no it's
not register i think so or it's a
crocodile cafe
it's on the same street that's all i
know
oh no i just like all the asian grandpa
father figures in every single how many
are there's only two of them
pat marina on that dude whatever his
name is what about the guy from last
dragon that his sensei it's the last
dragon that's dragon the bruce lee story
the bruce lee roy story the bruce lee
that [ __ ] too i'm trying to think of him
jackie chan plays that in karate kid the
return or whatever oh yeah
it'll be so funny if there's enough
you know back then everyone thought like
asians new martial arts so what if
there's a story where this kid like bugs
the [ __ ] out of this old asian man to
teach him martial arts all right you
guys gotta make the movie let's do it
man there's no [ __ ] and he doesn't know
jack [ __ ] did you learn martial arts as
kid yeah you learn martial arts right
now you obviously know much did you
learn martial as a kid no not i think
everybody i think we all did except him
no i didn't i think that's a 90s thing
like yeah everyone everybody took their
kids to like karate dojo not as much a
filipino thing you get put in you you
get given an instrument right ninja
turtles was like
everybody wanted everybody everybody
that was that was the thing for kids
like
power rangers was huge like in the 90s
right yeah and if you didn't want to be
a ninja you'd be a [ __ ] hockey player
that fought people at night with [ __ ]
hockey sticks
that's true unconventional alternative
antsy hero
kempo karate and judo man
yeah
let's go let's go that was the orange
belt yellow belt i thought judo was so
lame though but i'm so glad i did it
because when you're a kid you know you
want to you want to kick and pop yeah
you want to oh yeah you're nice
like throwing each other all day yeah
and i'm like man dad why'd you put me in
this [ __ ]
i still know something just don't punch
at me dude
see look at that dude
like that i'm gonna do it again what
belt were you i got my black belt in
karate you did yeah
why are you standing on the bed
why are you starting all the bears for i
could have killed you right there that's
why
you are a black belt aren't you no i see
you have a pasadena style it's nice
a rose bowl style